plus aucune activité chez kone krenz
depuis hier les salariés sont sous le
choc
la direction a présenté un projet de
suppressions d'emplois 115 postes sur
les 142 que compte le site de saint
vallier pour les représentants du
personnel et les syndicats
les conséquences sur l'ensemble du
bassin minier vont être dramatiques
on va licencier 115 familles c'est pas
du 200 m 115 personnes comme ça à la
porte
ça n'impacte que toutes les familles il
légendes et des crédits on a tous une
vie de famille
andorre s'est pas possible de nous ce
qu'on veut c'est absolument sauver nos
emplois c'est pas eux ils ont ils n'ont
pas de coeur dans un communiqué la
direction annonce que ces suppressions
de postes ne sont qu'un projet des
discussions sont toujours en cours avec
les instances du personnel reste qu'un
calendrier fixé la production s'arrête à
la fin de l'année le site est démantelé
début 2021
seule une activité de service après
vente serait maintenue avec une
vingtaine d'employés
amers certains salariés estiment que
rien n'a été fait depuis des années pour
remplir les carnets de commande en 2018
les dés sont lancés un chariot élévateur
enfin ces mêmes trois modèles sur en
suède et en chine et je leur ai dit mais
pourquoi vous le faites pas à montceau
non toute façon ils sont arrivés en nous
disant il y aura pas de nouveaux
produits si les pouvoirs publics ont
aussi vivement réagi dans un communiqué
la préfecture de saône-et-loire a
fermement rappelé au groupe finlandais
propriétaire du site
son obligation d'explorer des pistes de
reprise si ce n'est pas le cas le
procureur de la république serait saisi
les employés de koné craintes vont se
réunir demain matin pour décider
d'éventuelles actions de protestation
contre ces suppressions d'emplois lundi
ils devront reprendre la production de
porte containers jusqu'à la fin de
l'année
mais les salariés n'ont plus le coeur à
l'ouvragé